hey youtubers it's Charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions on my
Game of Thrones video last night
I think everyone feels like episode 8 is
the best episode this season so far I
mean we still have two more but it's
gonna be really hard to top a white
Walker battle most of the questions that
I saw people asking were related to that
but I did try to include some Arya and
Cersei stuff too
Ramsay gets really pissed when you
forget him - so here we go just careful
for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet starting questions snute
soul asks are there different levels of
whites aside from the top commanders and
the ones that seem like skeletons so
you're talking about like you know the
difference between White Walkers whites
you know everyone that we saw basically
it's a lot simpler than you think so
what you have from the top down you have
the night's king then you have White
Walkers then you have the whites they
also they're also able to turn animals
that's how they ride the horses they
have the undead horses so that means
they can turn other animals too so you
can consider those a different type of
white they don't really differentiate
between humanoid whites they're all the
same most people feel like winds of
winter is gonna be the book where George
R Martin gets really deep on White
Walkers and in their culture as for
right now we don't know a lot about
what's going on inside the minds of
whites it doesn't look like it's a hive
mind situation it looks like they have
some sort of basic mental functions like
they know what their target is probably
defined by the night's king or the White
Walkers that are commanding them it's as
if the white Walker gives them their
target and then they just go after it
it's as simple as that you know until
they fall like whenever they pour it
over the cliff they were temporarily
immobilized until they reanimate it
again so you can slow them down but you
can't destroy them unless you use one of
their specific weaknesses
next question handsome jack asks can
Valyrian steel actually kill the others
or does the sword Jon used something
special like light bringer you're
talking about the weapon of azor Ahai
like the flaming sword no Valyrian steel
is one of their weaknesses White Walkers
the night's king in the whites have some
known weaknesses one being Valyrian
steel as we saw you know Jon Snow
dragonglass which we also know about
they're also weak against dragon fire
but but obviously there are no dragons
in Westeros right now we also saw in the
season four finale that they're weak
against the magic of the children of the
forest
next question Bart - asks what do you
think Ramsay needs
his twenty men four but he's basically
just gonna lead a raiding party against
Stannis
he feels like they're stuck in the snow
so they're completely vulnerable this
could be one of those big changes from
the book so I'm really hoping to see
Ramsay get his ass handed to him I think
it's the synopsis for episode 9 but it
says you know Stannis's gamble pays off
it sounds like Stannis is still gonna be
around through the season finale and I
don't know if Ramsay's going to die but
it would be awesome if Ramsay were to
get captured just like the show had like
a really special fate in mind for
Joffrey you know for some of the worst
people on the show I'm hoping it's saved
something really special for Ramsay
that's actually a good question for you
guys
if Ramsay is gonna go somehow either
this season or next season how would you
want him to go I feel like the way a
character needs to leave the show like
the spectacled with which they leave
needs to be equal to the craziness of
their character so Ramsay being the most
awful person on the show right now it
has to have the most spectacularly awful
ending next question crazy back asks do
you think that they'll take elements
from the young grift storyline when
Danny eventually comes to Westeros so
you're asking you know like things that
they cut out from the show will they
give those to Danny or other characters
a lot of it will just be in the form of
Easter eggs like in this episode they
mentioned at least like four book things
like Ramsay said a feast for crows you
know you know while we can get the
camera almost they'll just continue to
do that more and more as the show plot
diverges from the book plot but I do
think that they'll continue to reference
the young grift storyline and there's
always metaphors that you can draw up
you know sometimes they're kind of
far-reaching like saying that sir Jorah
is Jon connington is a bit of a stretch
they just have some similarities right
now without the writers you know coming
coming out in sinks specifically yeah we
referenced this one character or this
one storyline from the book it's really
open to interpretation just in the name
of fun I'm always willing to entertain
ideas but you know just just remember
that a lot of it is just fan theories
for now that just assume there is no
young Griff character on the show and
then that storyline is completely gone
and the Daenerys storyline will just
proceed according to what Dan and Dave
felt like george RR martin was gonna do
with her next question khalaqtu casks I
know everyone hates all eight but if
you're just a kid and your family got
slaughtered and someone wanted to help
the guys who did it
I'd be pretty salty too yeah there's
gonna be a whole lot of Olly hate at the
end of this season there's even like a
subreddit right now I think called I
hate oli so just be prepared for that
everyone I think all is gonna wind up
getting a lot of reverse joffrey hey
like you hate Joffrey because he's such
a douche because he's so crazy but
people will hate Olly for the same
reasons even though technically he's not
a character like Joffrey he's not an
evil character you're supposed to
sympathize with him but I mean some
things are just so ridiculous that you
can't forgive them next question
Cassie asks do the others practice blood
magic and if so maybe the night's king
captured bench and start to use his
blood somehow well you know we don't
there's a lot we don't know about the
White Walkers as far as we know their
magic is completely different from the
magic of the red God acolytes of both
gods you know White Walkers as well as
priests of the red God can resurrect
people so I mean there's certain
similarities and abilities but the way
they go about it feels like it's a
little bit different it's one of those
things that George r Martin just hasn't
explained get in the books that that's
why we're waiting for winds of winter
it's like please explain these things
they're very complicated very
interesting there are a lot of different
gods on Game of Thrones a lot of
different religions that I think are
distinct you know it's not like people
just misinterpreting things and it's
really just two gods but I think the
best way to think about white Walker
magic is primarily based on ice and
necromancy thematically it makes sense
that they would just put it forward as
is like a wintry looking type of magic
but just to keep making ice references
you know necromancy just the tip of the
iceberg there's no really good
explanation so you know I feel like
characters like Samwell are gonna
explain things like this in season six
in season seven the characters that read
a lot of books that there aren't a whole
lot of people alive there are masters of
those crafts and it's not like the
night's king is gonna do an evil guy
monologue anytime soon explaining his
grand plan and how everything works that
would be hilarious next question
dekappa source asks does winter follow
the whites wherever they go is it in
like do they control winter weather or
do the whites just move with winter
storms I would say it's a combination of
two you know the world is like slowly
getting closer but a lot of it has to do
with the magic of the great other the
night's king seems like he's pretty
powerful so I would say you know he
probably was a small level of control
over the weather but it's not like he
has like a winter Infinity Gauntlet
where he can just snap his fingers and
turn the world to complete winter
overnight so the winter storm that we
saw in this episode is probably
something that the White Walkers
in the night's king conjured up but
during the long night just imagine that
winter storm covering all of Westeros
next question
space gypsy asks since we found out
Valyrian steel is also capable of
killing White Walkers and it's in such
short supply
do you think that Jon will melt down his
blade into arrowheads for the wildlings
to use no I don't think they'll do that
they probably don't have anyone that can
reshape Valyrian still there remember
Tywin had to send for someone overseas
like there's such a rare trade they
didn't say specifically on the show but
Samwell does find like a cache of
dragonglass historically in the early
years after the wall was built like
right after the long night the children
of the forest would give dragonglass
shipments to the Nights Watch to help
them if for some reason the show just
decides to forget that plot point they
could always send someone back to
Dragonstone to get more because remember
Dragonstone is covered with dragonglass
so if they're smart enough to look for
it there is a lot more dragonglass that
they can use at the Nights Watch the
question is is will Alliser thorne in
his [ __ ] listen - Samwell and Jon
like will they go for dragonglass or say
that's all bullcrap right now about half
the Nights Watch only wants to kill the
wildlings they're not thinking about
anything else next question
Mayor Joe Bryan asks regarding Jorah
Tyrion should have advised her to send
him on a quest you're saying you know
instead of just like outright banishing
him you know I think he'll definitely be
back next season unless he dies in the
finale
don't worry like George just feels like
a character that's way too interesting
to throw him away he does have greyscale
but it's killing him slowly enough that
he could live through the entirety of
season six if the writers wanted to go
that direction but I feel like Daenerys
is going through the same type of
storyline is Jon Snow there's a lot of
like parallels between the two of them
Jon Snow started by battling the
wildlings then they realized that they
have a common enemy that's way worse so
they do they put their differences aside
and started working together I think
Daenerys is just like a few steps behind
that but she'll eventually realize that
she needs Dora's help because of this
bigger enemy of the harpies well if you
really want to compare like apples to
oranges between storylines I feel like
the harpies are Daenerys his version of
the wildlings she needs to turn all the
people of murine into her allies because
the real common threat is the White
Walkers even though she hasn't seen them
yet so I think you know unless Jorah is
marked for some spectacular gladdie
a death in the arena he will be back
with Daenerys and Tyrion by season 6
thank you so much everyone for so many
questions these are always a ton of fun
to do I did see a lot of people were
asking about when you know winter
officially begins
technically the citadel down in oats
hunt like the maesters of the citadel
defined when winter begins they gate
control the calendar that way there are
a couple different concepts associated
with that first there's winter like you
know winter is is like basically when
it's snowing all the way down in King's
Landing the long night as John said
would be like a winter that covers the
entire earth when it's like snowing in
Mereen a lot of people were also asking
about arya in the moneylenders so just
explain that real quick the reason jaqen
is seeking arya or you know cat of the
Canales everyone to think about her on
the moneylender is because he isn't
paying out what you would call insurance
money to the families of sea captains
who die at sea he's like a douchey
insurance agent who isn't paying out
insurance ain't congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner let's see
brave Katniss you win an HBO now
subscription just be sure to DM me on
the on the back end of my channel so
I'll get your contact info it's on the
about page a lot of you also asked for
like some specific bonus videos on white
walkers and stuff like that
I might do some updates but I have done
a few older videos like I did some
videos last show on that stuff so check
the description for extra links so just
in case you guys haven't seen it you can
click here for my episode 8 video from
last night and you can click here to
learn all about your on Greyjoy thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you